they say we're enemies  they say we're divided  they say we're supposed to hate each  other  but are they right  what's interesting is that they go to  the same bars  the same parties the same schools and  the same country clubs  together maybe they're on the same team  [Music]  maybe they're the enemy of course we  have differences  yes we don't agree on everything but we  have far more in common than differences  we're more alike than they want us to  believe  we all believe in freedom we all want  what's best for our kids  we all want great relationships we all  want a healthy life  we all enjoy a good meal with good  company  maybe it's time for us to not fall for  their tactics  maybe it's time for us to not be  manipulated maybe it's time for us to  realize  who has the power  and if we unite they  will no longer have the power to divide  [Music]  us  you